the question is kind of how virtual
reality will interact with or supplant
or challenge the theatrical experience
you know because that has proven very
durable the end of movie going is
something that's been predicted since
the first television set rolled off the
assembly line pretty much and and and
has accelerated in recent years this
idea well people are just going to stop
going to move there's going to be
something at home that's going to be so
great maybe it'll be goggles you know or
maybe it'll be a big TV that no one's
ever going to leave the house and go to
the movies again and yet people do and I
think people still will and and if some
enterprising producers or filmmakers or
technology companies can figure out how
to integrate the VR experience into that
that that could be really interesting it
could also be really strange i was at a
screening of of the virtual reality
stuff for The Times Magazine and there
were a bunch of people sitting in rows
of chairs and they were all gone like
this they're like with their little
goggles on sweetly weird instead of all
looking at the screen they were all kind
of together in the theater but in their
own little like enclosed bubbles one
thing that's true about movies are about
motion pictures let's say is how they
have it just how constant and how rapid
the technological change has been I mean
the movies have been a different thing
every single decade of their of their
existence it's remarkable to to look at
how how fast they move from you know
from the first Edison and Lumiere shorts
to you know the large-scale silent
features by by Griffith and chaplain and
von Stroheim and and the others and then
you know then there's sound then there's
Hollywood then there's color then
there's television and there's
widescreen and there's 3d and there's
digital I mean it just it happens really
really quickly and at any point it's
hard to predict what it's going to look
and I think it's a matter of the artists
figuring out what to do with it I mean
there's this new technology and the one
thing I'm sure of is that the the early
experiments with it that that looked
kind of so cool and so futuristic now
we'll a few years from now look so
bizarre and antiquated and strange